did you know that in jujitsukai is in
megami's grandfather was the leader of
the Zenon clan in volume 17 we got this
official diagram of the Zenon family
tree and it revealed that the previous
head of the family was toji's Dad
meaning he was also fushiguru's
grandfather although we don't know his
name it's highly likely that Grandpa
died before Megami was even born because
when fushiguro was super young the new
head of the clan was Toby's Uncle what
makes the situation even more
interesting is that it's highly likely
that megami's grandfather had the 10
Shadows technique if you want to find
out why then check out the full video on
my YouTube channel where I explain 10
Jiu Jitsu Kai's in facts he didn't know